hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime outpro and all for one
just defeated the heroes and stole a
major character's Quirk Deku and
shigaraki are about to have an
unexpected visitor that neither of them
really want to see and all of Japan and
even the whole world is in tears as they
witness the sacrifices of the pro Heroes
mha is absolutely unreal right now tears
are flowing everywhere we have to talk
about it you guys know the drill if you
enjoy our amateur videos you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now it only takes you
a second but it helps me out a lot with
that YouTube algorithm and if you are
one of the over 50 of people who watch
our videos but haven't taken the time to
subscribe do me a big favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell do it right
now by the way I recently made an entire
video on how Deku could have become a
villain if one important thing was
changed in the mha story I put a ton of
work into that video and it features
everything from epic editing to
professional voice actors voicing Deku
and other characters so please check it
out Link in the description and in the
pinned comment finally this video will
contain Boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned in the previous chapter we
learned that Makia willingly betrayed
old for one because he felt abandoned by
his master this means that Makia who is
of course an absolute monster and
possesses multiple overpowered quirks is
actively and willingly fighting with the
heroes and against all for one we also
learned that multiple members of the
media are now filming the climactic
battle between the heroes and villains
and labrava is also live streaming it to
tens of thousands of people through
gentle's YouTube channel because of this
the rest of Japan and the entire world
is now able to witness what is really
happening right now on the battlefield
this epic war is attracting the
attention of everyone including the
general public former Heroes who retired
International Heroes the U.S president
and even characters who up until this
point were movie only and as the battle
at gunga Mountain continues to rage the
absolute Chad lass Mount lady is
fighting so hard that she breaks the
giant wrench that she had been using as
a weapon yui from class 1B then tosses
her another object that she also
gigantifies like she did with the wrench
and this weapon is an item made by death
Mount lady and tokoyami are clearly
exhausted from the battle but they
refuse to give up and they go in for yet
another massive attack on all for one
Makia is also still fighting while Hawks
and others are providing as much support
as they can but even these overpowered
tag team attacks are not enough to take
over one down and he manages to delay
deliver a brutal hit to mount lady's
midsection she collapses to the ground
and minata Hawks and others are clearly
concerned about how serious her injuries
might be it's not looking good right
after that some sort of deadly energy
beam smashes into machia and this causes
him very serious injuries we then get a
look at the man who launched that energy
beam all for one but he barely looks
like a man at all as a result of all the
massive attacks that he has been
absorbing he looks more like a
decomposing corpse than a living
creature however thanks to his super
regeneration he is able to keep healing
himself no matter how much damage he
takes he looks terrible like some sort
of decayed skeleton and yet he is still
actively fighting and launching attack
after attack at the heroes another
energy beam then takes out the giant
dark shadow almost instantly and
tokoyami is severely wounded it as a
result of this attack I guess this makes
sense because the energy beam that All
For One is using seems to be potentially
light based like a light beam which
would of course be super effective
against Dark Shadow tokuyami would
actually have been dead if Hawks hadn't
sacrificed his own body in order to
provide some cover for tokoyami but this
result in Hawks also taking some
extremely serious damage all for one is
impressed with the power of his own
attacks now that he is young again he is
able to draw out the full potential of
every single one of his quirks which
means that they are now even more
powerful and more effective than they
were before all for one does say that
this comes at a cost and the cost seems
to be that he is reducing how much time
he has left before his body rewinds
itself out of existence but he clearly
feels that the sacrifice is worth it the
remaining Heroes try to keep going and
keep attacking but it's no use all for
one is too strong song and the heroes
fall one by one as an unconscious
tokoyami lays motionless on the ground
all for one grabs the injured Hawks by
the neck and lifts him up into the air
all for one says that he plans to steal
tokuyami's Quirk but Hawks keeps getting
in his way so all for one wants to make
sure that this won't happen again Hawks
tries to pierce over one with one of his
blades but even though the blade pierces
through all for one it has no real
effect all for one simply ejects the
blade from his body and easily
regenerates to make things worse like a
lot worse we see that all for one is
beginning to grow wings on his back
meaning that as he is holding Hawks by
the neck he is currently in the process
of stealing hawks's Quirk a frustrated
Hawk says that it just isn't fair that
even though all for one's body is
rewinding he still gets to keep all of
his quirks I mean I see where Hawks is
coming from but we have to assume that
all for one knew that this would happen
other otherwise he wouldn't have used
rewind in the first place just then
minita gets involved for some reason
even though he'd be better off running
as far away as possible and hiding
immediately Minato throws one of his
balls at all for one and it sticks to
the back of his leg with tears in his
eyes minota begs all for one not to
steal tokuyami's Quirk because that
would turn him into a cringy edge Lord
Minato says that if all from wants to
steal a truly childly Quirk he should
still pop off because he would give him
the best hairstyle ever minata is a
pretty massive Chad and his hairstyle is
pure Riz Jokes Aside this was Brave of
minata but of course it has no effect on
all for one he's not about to fall for
some cheap desperate tricks he is on a
tight schedule all for one looks at
minata's Theory face and it reminds him
of jiro's face which was also full of
desperate courage and idealistic
commitment but all for one doesn't have
time for these Side characters or their
tears he is running out of time and he
needs to get out of there and find
shigaraki right now he takes off flying
and leaves the battlefield in Ruins with
all the heroes and hero students laid
out on the ground he now presumably has
hawks's quirks although I guess he
didn't end up taking tokoyamis because
he ran out of time seeing that the news
helicopters are flying around in the
area all for one mocks the heroes
because the entire world is now going to
see how pathetic they truly are the
heroes lost they got absolutely bodied
by just one man and they couldn't
protect anyone or anything the chapter
then switches Focus to the underground
civilian shelter where all the civilians
who were supposed to be evacuated from
the UA are currently located as I
mentioned in my previous videos the fact
that these civilians didn't make it to
their Rendezvous point with the shiketsu
students means that something went wrong
something that probably involves all for
one's spies who had infiltrated the
shelter many chapters ago apparently the
shelter lost power the lights went out
and now everyone is stuck there
underground the civilians inside the
shelter are watching the big battle
unfold on their tablets phones and other
devices and they are devastated to see
what's happening to the heroes we see
the Todoroki is there some of those
overpowered Next Generation kids from
the remedial course Arc and many others
as well meanwhile tsukauchi and La
Brahma have been attempting to get to
the civilians but they haven't been able
to they know that all for one won the
battle at gunga Mountain and that he is
now heading towards shigaraki and the UA
but they can't seem to figure out what
is happening with the underground
shelter system even though la Brava
regained control of the security systems
some of the blocks that make up the
underground structure seem to be locked
from the inside and she can't seem to
unlock them on her end someone inside
the shelters has been interfering with
the security system someone is
sabotaging them the one who has been
tampering with the system is the male
spy who looks like an adult mob from Mob
psycho 100 he may have some sort of
electric work and he's using it to Like
Short Circuit the system he is waiting
for further orders from skeptic but he
hasn't been able to get in touch with
skeptic for a while and we of course
know why skeptic has already been
apprehended by the heroes thanks in
large part to La Brava the Spy isn't
exactly sure what to do now that he's
been cut off from his orders but he
knows that he has to do something
because once the big battle on the
surface is over all for one will emerge
as the ruler of the world and so the Spy
Can't Fail him he has to do something to
impress his new Overlord all for one so
the Spy starts using the Quirk to
actively damage the shelter and soon
parts of the shelter ceiling begin to
break and fall gun head Kendo and
tejutetsu react immediately and try to
prevent a large chunk of the ceiling
from collapsing on a couple of civilians
but the chunk of ceiling is so big that
it doesn't look like they'll be able to
fully stop it nevertheless before the
students can make their move death arms
grabs the huge chunk of ceiling and
prevents it from falling on the
civilians realistically Kendo and
tatsutetsu may not have been able to
handle this one so death arms
intervening with his super strength
Quirk at this exact point may have saved
the lives of the civilians as we know
death arms already retired and gave up
on being a hero following what happened
in jakku but after seeing what the other
Heroes have been going through on the
battlefield he simply couldn't help
himself his body moved on its own and he
did what he had to do he used his
strength to protect the innocent tears
run down death arms his face as he
remembers how Deku ran to save bakugou
from the sludge villain back in chapter
one and he did it without any regard for
his own safety or well-being after all
at the time he was quirkless this
reminds death arms of what it means to
be a true hero and it reminds him of
what true courage looks like the final
page takes us back to kamino where an
injured Shoto is leaning on Ida for
support Shoto tells Ida that it's not
over yet the battle is not done yet and
in the Final Chapter we see that close
to them and watching them from above is
none other than the hero killer stayed
and so it looks like all for one might
have been wrong about the effect that
the media footage of the battle is going
to have on the public he seems to think
that seeing the heroes lose again will
convince everyone that fighting is
pointless and that all hope is lost
but it seems that the media footage is
having the opposite effect civilians and
former Heroes and international Heroes
and everyone else is seeing how hard the
current heroes are fighting against
seemingly impossible odds and this is
reminding them of what true courage
looks like what true heroism looks like
all for one's overconfidence may be
backfiring on him again because as Shoto
said to Ida it's not over yet this
chapter really did try to make us feel
too contradictory things at once on the
one hand horikoshi really wanted us to
witness the overwhelming strength of all
for one's power I mean he literally
cleared the battlefield and took down
Makia Mount lady tokuyami hawks and so
many others on his own he then mocked
the heroes and flew away towards
shigaraki meaning that the heroes at
gunga straight up failed in their main
mission the mission to stop over one
from leaving and reaching shigaraki but
at the same time we saw people like
death arms and Shoto and others deciding
that even with everything that happened
they won't give up they will continue
fighting all for one's victory at gunga
did not make them lose hope on the
contrary it inspired them to keep going
in order to honor the sacrifices of all
those Heroes who kept fighting against
impossible odds so the chapter makes us
feel both hope and hopelessness at the
same time and I personally like that all
for one did indeed defeat all of his
enemies and he is now on his way to
shigeraki this is something that I and
many others predicted all for one can't
just die or rewind himself out of
existence without ever seeing shigaraki
and Deku again he will make it to the UA
Battlefield and he will try one last
time to reclaim his vessel ultimately I
believe that he will fail and the true
final villain will be shigaraki not all
for one but all for one definitely isn't
done yet he still has some tricks up his
sleeve now of course we are all
expecting him to try to place his Quirk
Factor inside shigaraki in order to
force his new vessel to obey him and
then an internal struggle is likely to
occur but as I mentioned in previous
videos I actually hope that for all for
one's final trick he attempts something
much more unexpected I hope that he
tries to take over deku's body instead
of shigaraki because that way he would
possess both the all-for-one and the one
for all Quirk factors at the same time
if he could somehow win that internal
struggle he would become the perfect
villain a true Quirk God I mean we still
have to be realistic mha is deku's story
so we know that if all for one tried to
take over his body Deku would win in the
end but it would be really interesting
to see what kind of being Deku would
become if all for one took control of
his body even just temporarily just
imagine all for one using deku's body to
use both all for one and one for all at
the same time against his enemies and
while he's doing this no one wants to
actually kill him because they don't
want to kill Deku taking over deku's
body would be just the perfect devious
Master strategy for All For One it makes
all the sense in the world what do you
guys think will all for one try to take
over shigaraki's body or maybe deku's
could he possibly succeed in doing
either of these two things what would a
villain Deku who is controlled by all
for one and possesses both all for one
and one for all look like is stain
finally about to join the heroes and if
he does what difference could he make in
this battle don't forget to share your
thoughts down in the comments below and
if you want to watch a detailed video on
how Deku could have become a legit
villain and teamed up with stain if one
change was made to the mha story check
out my video on what if Deku became a
villain Link in the description and in
the pinned comment if you enjoyed this
video and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like right now and
if you're one of the over 50 of people
who watch our videos but haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet I'm asking you
again to please do me a huge favor and
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications until next time see
ya Space Cowboys